- Il y a quatre ans,stations deu
la décrépitude de l'Hôpital
Maisonneuve-Rosemont.
- C'est des morceaux qui se dét,
des murs de l'hôpital.
- En 2018, on voulait donc
accélérer la reconstructionpourd
en 2025.
YVAN GENDRON, ex-PDG, CIUSSS
de l'Est-de-l'Île-de-Montréal
- L'espérance de sept ans,
que ce soit plus rapide, là.
- Mais le projet pourraitourrait
s'étendre au moins
jusqu'en 2032.
Mais est-ce que vterminer l'ene
avant, par exemple, 2032?
JEAN-FRANÇOIS FORTIN VERREAULT,
PDG, CIUSSS Est-de-l'Île-de-Mtl
- Ah, c'est certai
- La Société québécoise
des infrastructures pense qus pe
ça pourrait même s'étendre
jusqu'en 2035.
Le projet doit ê explose.
Évalué l'an passé
à 2,5 me coût du
projet a été révisé à la hausse
à 4,2 milliards l'hiver dernier.
Une augmc refuse pour l'instant
d'allonger la différence.
Mais avec 2,6 milliards,
vous ne pouvez pas faireité de ?
- C'est - C'est - C'est extrême,
évidemment, avec l'augmentations
faire la totalité de ce quiétai.
- On pourrait donc réduire
la superficie du tiers
et procéder en plusieurs étapes.
- C'est certain qu'on veut faire
la premère étape qui va répondre
à 720 lits.
Ça, il n'y a pas de doute.
- Plusieurs pensent que ce sera
carrément impossible.
en soins Est-de-l'Île-de-Mtl
- 2,6 milliards, de façon
réaliste, ce n'est pas
suffisant. On a besoin de plus
d'argent que ça. Ça, c'est à peu
pour l'hôpital qu'on construit
actuellement sur la rive-sud
va être deux fois plus petit que
Maisonneuve-Rosemont.
VINCENT MARISSAL, porte-paro
- On se met la tête
dans le sable, parce qu'à
2,5 milliards, c'est impossible
selon tous les calculs,
alors, on est peuttre même
5 milliards et plus on attend,
plus ça sera cher.
- Autre défi onéreux : l'édifice
principal, qui est cruciforme,
devra êpatrimoniale.
- Les goûts sont dans la nature.
Chacun peut juger.eut juger.eut,
ça reste le vieux bâtiment
qui tient avec de la broche.
où est-ce qu'il est totalement
désuet.
de l'Hôpital Maisonneuve-
Rosemontplombée
par l'inflation, comme
bien d'autres projets
qui doivent être révisés
nné l'explosion
des coûts de construction.
Ici Davide Gentil